but then she goes yeah when you were a
kid you were like every day you would
come up with toys and you would ask me
to like play and I'd be too busy and
she's like I felt like that that did
something like negative too and I was
like I must have like fixed it
found a way to play by yourself or
something and now Ryan pranks everyone
the whole time
now I'm a schizophrenic
[Music]
welcome back to another great episode of
careful boys today we have Nick and
Colleen over here we got Joe and Anthony
hey and then we have it even better Joe
right here
uh question of the day right here is
gonna be a hard one
or just a really major one what is a
mistake that your parents made that has
positively shaped who you are today oh
interesting
and are you even aware of it
right yeah you might not be until this
is I was the mistake yeah yeah that's
the obvious answer I had this uh talk
with my buddy because
um
we were talking about how things that
people feel sorry for us about are
actually the the obstacles we needed to
become successful so for his story is
his dad had a gambling problem and they
owned a couple of donut shops one day he
woke up
seeing repo people and the cops at their
house just taking [__] like TV all that
and he's like what the [__] so uh The
Donut Shop was under his mom's name so
the the livelihood wasn't taken away
thank God right so him and his brother
and his mom was just they worked really
hard to like keep the family business
going so they can eat
but that
pushed them to becoming the entrepreneur
that he is today making like 30 mil a
year wow 30 million yeah he's this guy's
Cambodian yeah Cambodian Chinese but
those were the kind of like the it was
like the building blocks for him going
oh [__] like
building a business being financially
responsible taking care of your family
all these things are so important he did
it as a kid so from that jump start
which he could have blamed his parents
and been like you stupid dad with a
gambling problem and all that but his
relationship with his dad got healed
after that he took care of them and and
then also I think like he was talking
about how like a lot of his money goes
to charity because it wasn't he didn't
get into business for the reasons of
personal gain it was to save his family
so then like all of his business
decisions have been charitable he didn't
know it yet and then when he got into
charity and he was helping Cambodia
build he was like oh [__] this is what I
what my passion was he's been doing his
taxes all wrong the whole time
but I'm like that's true because like a
lot of people can grow up blaming
you gave me this trauma you did this to
me but then I'm like out of like out of
that trauma though what did it jump
start
um yeah and for me it was independence
from my parents thoughts and them
infecting me with stupid thoughts what
like what kind uh so like
I see a lot of my friends and their
lifelong fight with their father right
of like
trying to get approval or like
acceptance or certain things
and then for me I wasn't influenced by
his thoughts and his stupid guidance so
like
they might have stupid ideas and then
you might believe that into your teen
years and then on and then you you might
be kind of it might be like 30 when you
realize oh my dad was wrong and he was
telling me stupid [__] but I was
following him because he was my role
model
but from 14 on I was able to develop and
test and and figure out my own thoughts
which freed me from the influence bad
influence which was him
yeah
Anthony you got anything I mean I think
it's similar the only difference is I
don't make 30 million dollars a year
but I think seeing uh you know there's
just that feeling it's hard to say it's
a mistake at all you know because my
parents work really really hard just
like you know run into dry cleaners and
stuff like that but it's just like super
humble hard-working business stuff
um versus like something overly
successful but then just being a kid who
had like uh you know a very economy
class lifestyle you grow up with like
other other rich kids around you right
whether it be like in my own extended
family or like just like friends from
school and then you're just always when
you're young and naive and ignorant
you're just envious and you're just
always like man I wish I had this or
like I resent my parents you know what
I'm saying for like not being able to
like kick ass in life and do better for
me when you just don't understand the
complexities of life and just how the
cookie crumbles sometimes but then you
grow up with maybe a certain different
type of fire and I just feel like I was
given that fire you know by the the
things I found as my shortcomings from
my parents you know because I was like I
hated working at my parents dry cleaners
I was like I don't want to [__] clean
other people close it was just such a
disgusting feeling somebody bringing
their laundry and I'd be like look at it
with such disdain even marks yeah now
now I'm like that's you know an honest
job is an honest job right yeah right
right but it's like in your mind all you
think of every day when you're pissed
off being someone and you hate something
about your life you just build this
[__] fire that doesn't you know and
and then I think things like that
specifically made me want to just do the
[__] that I wanted to do and not do
stuff that I didn't want and I think
that I'm very thankful for that but it's
hard to say that I would look at that
now as like a mistake now that I've just
like gotten more mature and like like oh
[__] you guys also had to flee your
country during war time and like went
through something and sacrificed
everything and started over like I might
not have done better as a person back
then you know so it's kind of like you
appreciate but I'm thankful for that
fire I'm thankful that I was able to
turn that resentment into something that
makes more sense and appreciation
um because I am the only person in my
entire extended family I feel like
that's doing something what like where I
followed my curiosity and passion versus
just like structure and security but
that's also because my family was the
poorest out of my entire extended family
that like made it to America
that's how I see it you know um the
Barbara from Shark Tank yeah she was
talking about how she doesn't invest in
rich kids like they might have the
greatest ideas with the best connections
and she goes there's there's a
difference between poor kids with a
startup
or people with a background of like
something they need to prove because
they they've been broke or whatever she
says like there there's some there's a
difference because
one is like you need to make it the
other one is like oh this one fails I
can do it again I have the resources the
safety net compared to like the hunger
yeah so she says like there's a clear
difference and she doesn't she can't
teach that or show that
so I was like oh and in recently it's
true yeah
um this person talking about
personality traits that make someone
successful and one of them was a chip on
their shoulder
because of their background and they
need to prove something or they're angry
at something and they just don't want to
be like whatever right because it does
have a more competitive Spirit that's
true yeah it does do that so that
kind of backs up what you said about
having some type of
uh I wouldn't say trauma is the word
maybe it is but then you you grow up
thinking
how come the rich kids have it better
but do they yeah because then they don't
have that fire it does take you a long
time to realize that it's not
objectively different set of problems
because at this point when I see people
that don't have the fire and they're
looking
they fall into drugs they fall into a
depression because like they don't have
that thing that pushes them
yeah and I'm like oh I agree with that
so maybe what I needed was a little bit
of stress in my history to get there I
had that chip really hard and uh it was
because of a mistake that I felt like my
parents made why this was 1998.
and uh I was 15. I used to prep my I
used to practice piano outside of the
house because uh my my parents didn't
always like me doing it you know
uh by the time I got to my teens so you
rolled out your piano to your backyard
no I go to public pianos I go to hotels
and then I went to uh The Bonaventure
Hotel in downtown hotels to play piano
yeah or school and then there was The
Bonaventure Hotel at the time had a
piano in the lobby and then I would go
play there and then I would just like uh
get tips and just people would like
request songs I was just doing and then
on this day so you were good enough
already when you get there I thought you
were doing like Jingle Bells
no there's not one here you can't come
back here they're uh so I would play
there and then on this particular day
there was this staff from uh from the um
the jazz radio station from back then
and then the dude came up to me and he
was like dude you're a kid and you're
playing like this like we gotta have you
on on the radio and then they we were
talking for like a few hours and we got
arranged for me to come on and they were
gonna do what I did there like live on
the radio of like oh we're just gonna
tell you a bunch of like uh songs and
then you're gonna chain them together
just like you did here today they were
just like who the [__] does this and
then uh it wasn't as common back then I
think to be like a a piano bar pianist
but like a kid so then because you can't
even drink there yeah because I can't do
anything and they were and they were
just like amazed that I when I told them
oh I come here just to practice because
you know yeah that's crazy I couldn't
practice at home because my parents
would be like stop doing that and study
instead so then like uh they called my
house
and then my mom picked up and said no
we're not interested oh he's gonna be a
doctor [__] you yeah and they and they
just it just like snipped it right there
yeah and then on I had such a chip from
that happening that when I got into
dance I was like I don't give a [__]
what you guys think I'm doing this and
then that's when I was like defiant
about it so like that was the chip for
like wanting to be a dancer regardless
of like you know what the plan was for
me if it wasn't for them like cutting
that dream short then I don't think I
would have been as like on fire about it
you know I probably would have been
afraid to make make them unhappy but it
was because of that that I'm like I'm
not gonna miss another shot like that so
you gave up your Jazz dreams to become a
dancer yeah both things are gay I see
what you're saying
I feel like you're the one who made the
mistake
I feel incredibly lucky because my
parents they just said whatever it is
that you choose to do just make sure you
do it with 110 conviction and just
invest yourself into it and we'll
support you mer
but it's like not like necessarily we'll
support you as far as like money goes
like they certainly could to a degree
but only so far right we weren't super
wealthy
um but it was more so like we'll support
you emotionally mentally and obviously
we have your back and you know we want
you to succeed in the things that you
want to do yeah but I can't think of
like a mistake like a at least one that
I know of
what about you
I don't know about a mistake I think
it's more of just like
like for
when I was growing up my parents my
parents went and my sisters would always
like they'd always be talking [__] in
the house they're [__] always just
yapping about somebody else talking
about how this person does this and
whatever
um so I don't think it's more of like a
specific amount like a specific behavior
that caused me to change everything it
was more of an observation of how they
behaved right so for instance like for
my dad there was always a sentiment of
oh well your dad doesn't do what he
likes in his life like he had to pick
this job like for for him being a sound
editor he didn't really like it he was
always he didn't like doing that no I
guess not we're at a certain point in
time he got sick of it and then started
to want to do something else and because
you want to do a bunch of different jobs
that would put us sometimes in financial
hardship right according to my family
right so Me growing up I would always go
like well [__] I have to make sure
whatever I do with my life it has to be
something I'm interested in something I
have a genuine love and passion for and
then that'll be my path to
sustainability over a period of time
right so that's how I kind of thought
about how I was gonna go through so you
kind of learned off of his because
that's in your programming exactly right
so but it but it I don't even know if my
dad really didn't like those jobs or not
this is just right what that's their
opinion yeah exactly exactly right so
then I would go through my life making
sure that everything I did
money-wise would always relate back to
my interests and things that I wanted to
do so
yeah and I think that was really helpful
for me because
but there was definitely times where I
was like [__] this doesn't make any
money
I'm gonna make money I'm doing this and
there was but it taught me how to push
through and to make it work really you
know find a way to make it work and like
why not take no for an answer but
um I think whatever you you're trying to
do there's a there's a pocket that you
could find to make money or to have your
your Venn diagram of your interests and
monetary gain to to make it fit you know
but I guess that's mine so his dad was a
sound engineer for like the most major
movies through the 90s and like Indiana
Jones Lethal Weapon like crazy [__] to
think that he didn't like it is pretty
right and I'm sure I'm sure I'm sure he
did he liked it up to certain like he
must have hated when Keanu had to come
to your house and do Foley but I think
as as a person right you just get sick
of once you do something for a long
enough time sure and there's something I
didn't realize either until I started
working in my field and I'm like yeah I
kind of want to do some other [__] and I
would have like guilt about that but in
reality it's like no you just have to
whatever you pick next like you said you
have to put all the 100 10 or whatever
but that's an interesting programming
because you're you're listening to other
people's opinion on what your dad must
be thinking yeah so then it's like
seeing Yelp reviews instantly for
someone else's performance so then how
do you not agree eventually like oh yeah
I guess it's true yeah and then that's
about your household yeah that's another
thing too is I realize that like oh yeah
what people say all the time definitely
isn't necessarily the truth right like
it's it's so or it shouldn't always
influence you that strongly exactly
exactly exactly but that yeah there's
tons of things like that but
that was one of the bigger ones for me
like I remember I was thinking I was
like I can't let I can't do something I
hate and that's why and I remember when
I first started when I went to college
and I was like I'm a business major and
I took a couple of business classes I
was like [__] this I cannot do this but
then it's kind of Full Circle and I
realized for me to be able to excel in
my business I have to learn yeah yeah
and then I now I actually have a
Fascination where I'm like oh cool like
I'm learning more about it and I kind of
like it so it's you know that's the part
that's the key though it's the
fascination gets killed When someone
tells you what the end result already is
exactly if they're like oh no that's bad
this is good that's bad this is good
then it's like you can't just be in
wonderment anymore yeah you're like oh
why bother with this it's bad apparently
yeah yeah yeah and as of that at that
age or well because I'm the youngest and
I think I would always try to all my
decisions I would try to make would be
like just don't make anybody mad you
know just make sure you're doing the
right thing you know right don't Garner
disapproval yeah yeah in reality it's
like you end up kind of sometimes live
moving someone else's and you're not
exploring anymore yeah and you're just
worried about [__] up rather than a
real mistake yeah you're worried about
[__] up and like what Joe said you
got to make those mistakes you got to
kind of put yourself in those spots
where you're like oh then you can learn
from it it becomes a learning experience
and all that other [__] you know that's
right what about what about you cool Joe
Cool Joe anything anything even close to
like what maybe your your parents might
have thought was a wrong decision that
you turned into like a good outcome for
yourself I don't necessarily see any
like wrong decisions
um I can't say growing up you know I did
live with my mom and she kind of was a
little bit more lenient on me uh so I
stood with my mom until I was like five
and then uh I was kind of going down a
bad path I was at five years old what
did you do drug deal
it was like the Dave Chappelle's drug
Baby
the movie baby kids yes
you were stupid kid I was just I was
always getting into trouble I was like
stealing stuff getting into fights
um
but uh yeah so my dad saw me going
around like that path and stuff like
that so then he kind of stepped in took
care of me and then you know kind of
brought me into the person I am today uh
I don't really take anything away from
my mom you know she's going through a
hard time that time you know she got
herself clean and you know yeah got back
together uh I got herself back together
um but I don't really see it as a
mistake
um
but I do see it as like uh you know a
defining point to where it's like okay
hey like you know if I have kids what
kind of situation I'd want them to be in
and then now I feel like I'm at a point
towards like I try and hang around my
mom and dad more just to understand them
more and I feel like that's how I found
out more about myself because I see a
lot of the things my mom does I'll see a
lot of things my dad does and I'm like
oh so that's where I get that from that
comes from that comes from my dad I like
this about what my dad does I don't like
this about what my dad does yeah I just
pick uh pick and choose what I like that
goes on between both of them and I just
try to be the best person I can honestly
yeah
it reminds me of like you know the intro
of uh boys in the hood when Furious
Styles picks up the kid
shouldn't be a man yeah
[Laughter]
and then the household shift and he's
like there's rules in this house yeah
exactly can't just be running around
doing what you want to do but he's five
he's a cute little five here
too that's how the dads are you know
when they're little badass kids
yeah I think there's like
um
your question sounds like did you have
resentment and then later real life like
church switches to a positive yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
um and it doesn't seem like anyone here
holds on to that or like because we all
been through certain things but it's
it's easy to forget it because like when
you yeah when you ask the question I was
like there probably was a lot right yeah
and then later there's forgiveness and
understanding and you're just like yeah
and everything can be a positive but
then like when you're at this point
where you know those obstacles push you
to the corner in making big life
decisions but it it shouldn't happen
like nobody should have that kind of
[__] up [__] but like it happens and
then it just it kind of becomes a part
of who you are so it's like yeah yeah is
it always you're grateful for those
things yeah I don't think they're wrong
but the the crazy Revelation is like
when when like you sit and talk to your
parents about eras where you never
discussed it and they tell you like my
mom has has told me recently like she
was like
I regret not playing with you when you
were a kid and I was like what and you
don't even remember that but see that's
the crazy the things that they regret
but then she goes yeah when you were a
kid you were like every day you would
come up with toys and you would ask me
to like play and I'd be too busy and
she's like I felt like that that did
something like negative to you and I was
like
I must have like fixed it or something
yeah
because she sees that as a mistake and I
don't you find out a way to play it by
yourself or something yeah and now Ryan
pranks everyone all the time
foreign
[Laughter]